[Musique]
ouah
ce que
m
[Musique]
et toi
m
ok
[Musique]
rockeur nightclubbers créateur painter
et newcomers wacey lunettes noires pour
nuits blanches l'ardhis troy du samedi
soir bonsoir deux plombiers rockeur
tragédie par a dit je regarde sa vie
avec ses grands yeux de cocker interview
vérité in terris sting le casting madame
sting trudie styler elle flashe sur
gordon ray lema de kinshasa la brigade
combat c'est son dada ça va zaira ex
graffiteurs néo paynter speedy graphito
un peu barjot très mégalo le roi des
nuits va faire du bruit et si claude
challe était la réincarnation de dario
moreno kalfon la caisse plus avril au
portugal silvano berges héros un porto
d'alain decaux durak contre landry
castelot niro la mc contre rtl dick
rivers dominique pharand le limier de
nimier c'est frébourg olivier nimier
revival plateau tôle en exclusivité son
l'archange peter gabriel autour interne
you only for you de mesures de rock une
dose de littérature un zeste
d'impertinence que tous très très
secoués de lunettes c'est la recette lui
cette
sorte
vous n'y êtes pas à coller mystérieux
pour d'innocents
alors
[Musique]
jean les plus porteurs
ici
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ou start modèle économique des mutins de
plus m une chaise selon m on disait
oui
mesdames si tôt
she has three of
bricks
abidjan ça y
est fantastique
[Musique]
si
ce
n'est à nous hisser
[Musique]
au chili
joe cole aux canucks
[Musique]
attention exclusion exclu lui voici le
nouveau clip du plus hypes l'ex archange
mythique persiste dans le mystique avec
passion la bo du film de scorsese number
one chez les intégristes la dernière
tentation du christ quand c'est bon
comme ça nous on reste baba
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
à
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
c'était gabriel l'appelation selon peter
voici style est en train dé la chérie de
son mari son café dont bing pour sting
on lui pardonne interview open arms au
fait le famous et ils prennent tous
alors tous les styles heures tu es là la
femme épouse le sting le bien de la
chance je suis sûr qu'il ya beaucoup de
filles si qui quitte en vie il m'écoute
il a de la chance
ah bah ouais quand on le voit on en est
sûr lors des deux enfants avec lui mais
avant de le connaître une des
comédiennes et là maintenant tu reprends
ton ton métier de comédienne tu as
appris aux relevés créateur c'est ça
ouais pas mal comme école et rip it en
retour sinon oui mais tu as appris à
voir ou à faire du théâtre plus tard
[Musique]
il arrêtait pas
au festival de cannes en a mis 110 bars
de christine pascal eydoux the right
thing de spike lee il y a cinq mois de
savaria ce bond de nazes on était tous
fanas de fer games de mario orsini
musique giorgio moroder
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et quand tu va nous raconter l'histoire
faut raconter un peu ses distances c'est
un amant qui retourne rende les clés à
c'est parce que je
pensais comme une vache espagnole
non non non pas du tout dont l histoire
est que la femme et vannes ce soir c'est
moi et
incarcérés dans un loft avec un mamba 7
certains médias ce qui veut dire c'est
qu'ils ramènent les clés du au revoir à
le quitte et puis lui l'enferment à
l'intérieur d'un loft ok juste une
verrière au dessus il peut pas là la
fifa peut pas bouger elle va sortir de
là et puis lui se met dehors et puis là
un système pour contrôler tout ce que
fait le serpent et il peut voir ce qui
se passe avec elle parce qu'il a un
cockpit heures dans sa voiture et danse
à collier il a mis un petit micro coin
un micro émetteur micro me taire et puis
il a mis la même chose dans le dos du
serpent il peut les voir tous et qu'on
dit les voit tous ensemble il sait que
ça va s'approcher d'elle il l'a vu sting
le film oui j'essaie de voir qu'est ce
qu'il dit
il a très peur de sa peau
tu préfères sting aux gardois dourdan
qui est calé il ne répond pas avant
pourquoi il répond plus avant de gordon
non il répondra à sting mais dans
l'intimité tu l'appelles sting ou gordon
de l'intimité gg chevet pathé dia
berling non chez de faire
alors on va faire une interview à peine
de
nullité
[Musique]
la chose que tu préfères dans la vie
l'amour l'amour est mort physique ou
l'amour l'immatériel
d'amour tous les deux tous les deux et
la gym dano est la chose que tu détestes
dans la vie ce que tu ne supporte pas
l'injustice la justice oui je suis une
carte victoire mais je suis aussi oui
bac 6 janvier
c'est toujours des rois alors maintenant
le disque de sting que tu préfères de
police si tu pars sur le tennis au
destin alors elle estimé a créé beaucoup
de chansons douces de police oui
si tu pars sur une île déserte le cas
turmel dépôt je pense que mon favori
maintenant est aidé en cela tout seul
parce que
sur les s'agite sur l'argentine oui tu
étais des femmes qui sont les épaules de
mairie
sur le thème le moyen
chanson que tu aimes pas tu me manques
or il a fait ça je laime bien d'en faire
franchement je m'entoure il a fait cette
chose qui je n'aime pas la piste est ma
vitrine grotte avant c'est un peu pour
moi c'était peu
[Musique]
ça s'est su que tu aimes pas alors ce
que tu aimes en toi ce que tu préfères
en toi à moi oui vas-y j'aime bien la
petite tout et qu'on dit quand je peux
la sortir elle vient et elle peut
sourire et pense que que tout est très
amusant et très difficile pour le
capricorne le sourire cette oui tu as
raison c'est l'essentiel c'est raide et
quand j'ai le jour là et c'est très
heureux parce que c'est plus rare que
les autres est-ce que tu supportes pas
du tout en toi
j'ai quand je me fâche je suis à une
personne horrible ouais tu peux l'être
elle travaille pas très belle quand même
être encore merci mais quand je suis en
colère ja terrible au rite est ce qu'il
fait dans ces cas là tu en as et qu'est
ce qu'ils croient qu est-ce qui fait
faillite face à d'autres tumeurs et
qu'est ce que tu fais ce que tu préfères
chez lui
chez lui qu'est ce que tu veux dire
qu'est ce que tu préfères en lui par
ennui oui la chose de lui que tu aimes
le mieux
ça c'est difficile parce que certaines
normes qui
j'adore j'adore surtout tout le monde
mais
il est cette norme le plus intelligent
que j'ai jamais vu venir c'est son
intelligence que tu préfères en lui
ça c'est une des choses puisque pas mal
non plus est ce que tu aimes le moins
chez lui en lui bien un truc que tu
aimes pas haut mais il est content on a
parlé des as d'astrologie il est un
balance et le matin il dit un chose un
chose l'après midi celle d'autres et
pour moi qui est très
stricte change d'avis quand même oui
j'ai toujours tout qu'est ce qu'il ya de
plus sexy
lui qu'est ce qu'il ya de plus sexy que
si vous venez de sexuel
[Rires]
on est tous les deux je veux dire
écouter tous les gens sont très très
sexy
j'adore ce encore bel et bien selon levé
sur un torse nu quand
est ce que tu aimes le moins
de lui et bas volume de magma
il parle de prétentieux non je trouve
pas bon sens écoute ça c'est les
journalistes qui s il n'ya pas prendre
potentielles écoutes il est un homme
très intelligent
en plus il a une visage et le c'est très
beau ouais
il n'y a pas on dit en anglais swing
valse n'est pas un coup ainsi leur salon
il est très fier de ça dont je pense que
le mot prétentieux et aux mots de
journalistes qui sont vraiment jaloux
tous les
tuer mais pas
du tout
au tout
quoique star de rock avant
où
les
news en
outre m
[Musique]
doit tout un
marocain jouer
[Musique]
bon
à joe cocker neil young people
discovered yoyo l'astral comme une
manière de dire oui tokyo new album high
à qtel ce bateau l'edge bruit
multisports
est son enfant
oh
ghanem chef il ya wild planet
mu n'a rien de moins qu'une
majorité de
la saison
festive à l'axone bury festival de
lectures et new sound from my friends
and the very successful a nourri
choribit un hello kitty capteurs le top
des charts dans la soirée je n'en bois
manille kovalainen
mais mad dog and glory
[Musique]
il
y a
new york i love
you were
in nineteenth six
cinémas
wifag et vit aux etats-unis le vieux
jane fonda la théologie
[Musique]
j'explique ce
petit fils du
professeur
[Musique]
granby
un opéra qui s'est nouée oui la quête de
tête
[Musique]
seul
super compile pour le meilleur et pour
le rire coluche le luron pas dégueu
monde veut laisser hardy par dix
extraits de décalage justin zeh la
sieste toujours gêné bout le poteau de
cocteau jean marais dans son qg le ch et
les meilleurs juré l'an dernier la
ragazza ne sont pas par cannes pour le
pli rossellini accuse t rica avec un nom
pareil il ne pouvait faire que des
lunettes de soleil beau soleil les
lunettes de lunettes c'est lui elle fait
du dirty aux mamas regardez la bien il
sera star demain sapphire
malgré toutes ces galères jo restera
toujours notre cocker 45 ans d'âge c'est
leur qu'héritage pour la blonde une
louve nothing to lose one night of
things du septième album bonhomme il
chante one de maicon comme dirait
sherlock paulo
guitare
[Musique]
simple com
je t'aime bien avant son
envie qu'ils sont les mongo
les skis wismes d'un homme est mort
moi en tout le monde voit tout
adjoint au bureau du consul adjoint au
maire de chaumont
des couloirs laquelle
on converse
enfin nous cache-t-on
baird saliou
même mike ans
[Musique]
tu souhaites ce moment
vivre dans le monde
[Musique]
by benzaie tuteur occupée où il a pu
boire
je me
a besoin
[Musique]
thème chaque fois
gbagbo
avec 1
à l'honneur
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
messieurs
tomek
à temps
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
d'accord
comme tout
or en avait le droit
[Musique]
à
deux mois
[Musique]
que ferons nous
à quai
thomert m
y à fond
[Musique]
voilà
une allure
au menu
[Musique]
et joe cocker laval 7 juin zénith le 33
sort le 5 voici olivier frébourg nimier
de retour en plein revival il était au
low prix milliers mardi dernier de thé
par le fouquet remis à frédéric berthe
et pour daimler s'en va éditions
gallimard
alors olivier frébourg tavannes trois
ans tu bosses au figaro tu as fait
sciences po ça rime et eut publié un
bouquin qui s'appelle roger nimier
trafiquants l'insolence vos éditions du
rocher dans la collection d
infréquentable pourquoi les
infréquentables parce qu'on a voulu
faire une collection sur des écrivains
il y avait une légende qui était un peu
scandaleux et c est autre chose que des
écrivains laboratoire alors ses écrits
pressé comme on disait en parlant de 10
ans le rendement offert une interview
pressé interview
on va commencer par nimier un an nimier
d'abord il ya les gens voyaient les
bagnoles il ya les femmes qui allaient
blague puis après on verra les bouquins
qu'il a fait alors les bagnoles avec
jaguar way martin aston martin qu on
appelait ça je savais pas une gaston
martin à cause de gaston gallimard
pourquoi parce que c'est lui qui lui
avait offert non parce que grâce à ces
grâce à ses droits d'auteur ni me avait
pu s'offrir cette aston martin dont le
verre la fatale puisqu'elle un accident
dans l'ouest ouais tu dis que c'est plus
chic de mourir dans l'ouest bah oui je
crois que c'est plus chic de mourir
par l'ouest que ça veut dire et un truc
bonsoir ça fait partie des légendes
aussi c'était la mode voyez le sagan
57,6 à la mode 60 cristaux mode udine 1
2 une semaine ou deux avant lui n'ont
ses mains avant lui ouais et mais
justement c'est parce que ces écrivains
qui ont un destin foudroyé sont souvent
des des modèles pour une très belle
jeunesse c'est l'époque où la
littérature française mouret comme james
d voilà d'ailleurs on a comparé
je me dis qu'elle est femme il ya
beaucoup regrettent h et l'importance
aux femmes nimier
beaucoup d'importance aux femmes c'est
un peu comme loyer la rochelle avait
découvert des formes des actrices
beaucoup c'était la femme avec qui il
était pour son accident ça ne servait de
l'arrco oui
une jeune femme très très peur elle
travaille sans arrêt non non c'est
je devais manquer ce très beau très beau
j'ai rêvé ouais elle avait écrit un
roman c'est plus la messagère sous
influence kraken et puis voilà
ce sont ces véhicules et de blandin a
dit que c'était elle qui conduisait de
poids que c'est vrai oui je crois que
c'est vrai on n'a aucune preuve formelle
mais
tout le monde faisait gros j'ai convié
trop bien pour avoir un excellent ans
les femmes les actrices des aventurières
s'était accordé sa vie avec la
littérature des salines oui il a
confondu la vie la littérature belle
leçon mais il y avait beaucoup de
gravité aussi celle très grave je pense
qu'une grande leçon rien les livres à 23
ans c'est à dire à tonnage il a publié
les épées alors c'était l'histoire d'un
jeune milicien charmant ce qui était
assez fou à l'époque parce qu'on était
en pleine existentialisme en plein
marxiste était le triomphe de sarp de
camus ça fait un scandale terrible ça
fait un scandale parce que
mieux met en scène un milicien qui est à
la fois miliciens et
résistant alors ça c'est l'art du
paradoxe et nimier justement prendre un
peu contre-pied de ce n'est pas
formidable
justement
que l'historiographie est extrêmement
résistant réalisation là le roman c'est
ce qu'ont chars de l île devenue très
amie avec jarden à une époque où
chardonnay des sulfureux comme ça sert
qui connaît les gens sulfureux chardonne
marrant
parce que lille et remettez ans à dire
que c'est des écrivains qui avait
discrédité pendant la collaboration
parce que bon ils ont une idée ce n'est
pas les allemands et puis il a décidé de
remettre en selle et puis
donc des gens comme moment comme
chardonne comme fraigneau sert à
l'accent très cher aux charges et puis
par goût de la provocation également
j'étais scandalisé les comores ans avec
les
ai pas été élu à l'académie par exemple
a été élue dix ans après d'ailleurs
l'été les dix ans après il a pas vu non
il a vu ses copains c'était les usa
enfin les hussards quand jamais existé
d'ailleurs qui n'ont existé que dans le
sas est une invitée dans l'opuscule de
franck moyens à ses copains c'était
blondin laurent déon week et stéphane
etc et quand grand ami de stéphane et
quai kléber haedens aussi les huit
sortes sont jamais réunis se font
ensemble bon c'est pourquoi dans une
pizzeria et paris mais
bon il y avait on avait vraiment pas de
sympathie des uns pour les autres ça
membres c'est une école qui a été créé à
posteriori oui c'est bon c'est une
invention d'un enfant qui est brillant
d'ailleurs donc voulait épingler ces
écrivains de droite très désinvolte mais
il était très proche des gens comme
comme l'a été comme
comme eric ollivier aussi par la caisse
tu penses de ce mouvement encore une
fois complètement inventée par garcin
dans l'événement du jeudi à quelques
années les nouveaux usages bezsonoff ou
à un
peu ce qu'est ce que tu veux mais je
crois que c'est bon après tout je crois
que l'aîné luis arce ont quand même des
gens beaucoup plus fréquentable comme
celle tournier par exemple qui veut être
hervé bazin
différent de l'original dit ouais mais
ce sont des écrivains justement qui font
autre chose que des livres qu'il ya un
art de vie
et puis ce sont des gens qui te donne
envie d'aimer la littérature et
tout l envie d'écrire aussi c'est quoi
qui t'a poussé vers nimier
j'ai découvert ni mais comme je raconte
là dans une villa au bord de la mer
c'est grâce à une jeune fille
c'est une jeune fille n'a mérité avec
moi qui adore élimine arrêtait pas de
parader
de lui est alors un jour agacé j'ai lu
ce livre j'avais cette fois sont à des
sujets d'intérêt spread est jolie elle
le blue le bleu au sahara elle y est
c'est encore trouvé la faille le dos et
revenir les actuels ni miel du pente
très actuel très dans l'air du temps il
va revenir en force c'est évident que ça
va être parce que je crois qu'on est un
peu une âme à générations est une
génération qui souffrent qui posent à
notre mal du siècle ces charges se
mettre à penser et c'est un peu
désarçonnés et je crois qu'on diminue
elle va trouver quelqu'un qui
capable de faire le coup de feu
contre l'époque et ougandais j'aime bien
que jeune film conduisent
dégager comme france est beaucoup plus
dangereuse de kinshasa voici ray lema
poussé par island et toute la bande de
black toile levier balthus et voilà
qu'avec salif keïta c'est l'élite de
l'afrobeat kerry quatrième album dingue
nov
[Musique]
ils commettront ap
au niveau
[Musique]
avec ton ami sens
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
la maison
ac dc
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
m
[Musique]
ces terres et lehmann auteur de la bo de
black mic mac c'est fou ce qu'on apprend
cette émission les en voici speedy
graphito drôle le pinceau que cet oiseau
interview soap un lapin à speedy
graphito ça te fait chier quand on sait
que c'est un graffiteur way
[Applaudissements]
pourquoi parce que gratuit dit c'est un
petit truc et la peinture c'est un drôle
d'artiste je suis un retard this way en
fait a quand même été connue avec des
trucs au pochoir sur les murs de paris
et dont le passage coûte est quand même
moins sûr quand même je regrette pas
mais c'est mon ca fais ça tu poses qui
quatre ans que j'y passe rien ce
cauchemar sur elle sur les modes paris
c'est l'histoire ancienne et quand on
parle de la ruée vers les ans est fléché
pourquoi cette fichiers ça ne sera pas
plaisir à jaffer
n'a rien à voir ni ton pays une belle
affiche ministre la culture et puis tu
veux pas qu'on n'a pas développé une
belle affiche et donc j'ai fait une
belle affiche pour eux
c'est tout quoi ouais bah tu regrette
d'avoir fait ça non je préfère faire ça
que nous avons été assez habile avec les
médias quand même nom d'abord tendance
speedy graphito c'est bien évidemment la
situation dramatique observé ben si tu
veux pas qu'on parle de graffitis
maintenant c'est vrai qu'au départ ça et
des noms
saadi
ouais ben 10 ans pas mal ouais c'est
chez passe et moins commercial
changer un alléchant sauvage sur les
retraites c'est trop tôt at all star
magazine aussi speedo way qui attaquent
gloire complètement le trajet du ce
magazine mais j'en revenais pas assez le
couple bat as mal être
s'est il ya des jeux c'est le magazine
du fan club il ya des petits chats
marchandising d'enfer
pour tous les foules à nancy 9e demande
pas où j'ai commencé à recevoir des
lettres de fans
et pour leur fair-play savez communiquer
avec eux donc surpris un magazine les
gens voient pratiquement gratuitement
c'est vrai il prévient françois niveau
qui fait des jeux à 1
je serai pied si tu étais pas ce pays du
golfe
ah bon je voudrais pas que quelqu'un
d'autre j'ai pas mon
nom ou la main qui t'a bien la main j'ai
bien mené mon père spirituel gepan ont
été influencés par quoi rayhana qui
blâme à twente accusé dé reprendre la
main qui ont des bilans il faisait bien
bas et cân tho répudiant du salagou
lâches qui était beaucoup de lui dire
non
grâce à ses victoires la bd cette
influence et apple
satisfait
des billets sera très intéressant ça
s'est perdu tadic a ce qu'il faut lire
une première deuxième troisième en face
à d'autres atouts tueur et pour tout
dans une seule image l'histoire et l'art
maya s'est inspiré le pré colombien éric
allard a spec ops débit 4g mais qu'en
même temps on fait un tableau
je m'appelle et me dit que je vais vite
l'infection
ça dépend
ça peut être long a plu ce com
l'étoile qui se place tout soit sa
taille
et d'autres matches et pas qu'à ce jour
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
vendu cher non avons passé
normal son attention que ce soit pas
trop cher parce que
je trouve ça bien de pouvoir pendant que
ce soit un truc la route
c'est pas cher les gens pensent que ça
va bien tout c'est ça ouais mais ça je
m'en fous tant pis pour eux ils
n'achètent pas et puis que ça vaudra
très cher et si tu les as chez nous
d'autant qu'il sent lâché trop un ouais
c'est cool quoi comme genre de musique
ne suit pas
j'écoute ma musique ah bon awang ledent
à ckoi le bon de le brancher un groupe
j'ai fait les deux oui ma femme sharon
cuisine de la maison glas
et puis bon bah petit truc c'est que ça
je poussais la radio la radio quand ce
travail va pas bouder chez toi
moribonds
première tournée en du temps
j avais je pas une définition de quoi ça
sert à quoi tels moyens terrestres j'ai
pas de l'impatience graphito amis
artistique génie artistique bâtiment
faire
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et voici le festival de challes néo
edger noceurs badouch heures sapeurs
night clubbers et chanteur à ses heures
il mise sur la cover de dario moreno le
bel canto voici le ces magnifiques du
loustic à l'afld le brake
[Musique]
hélas
j
tout bleu
et bce
[Musique]
m
son cas
avait
kit fleurs
m
il y a
faire un jour
sem
[Musique]
la
mer tu parles
[Musique]
pékin
mais c'est comme ça
mallet
guay
tu es ma nuit d'amour qui dure
[Musique]
voir paris
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
chaud
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
oh oui
ok
mais
gamin
[Musique]
jours
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
c'était claude challe à lui la timbale
clos te fais pas la maladresse ces
tombes là une test mais gaffe à la veste
alors c'est magnifique aujourd'hui ouais
super comme tous les jours d'ailleurs
pourquoi tu as pris 1,10 dario moreno
d'abord parce que j'adore d'abord
d'ailleurs mon amour c'est un grand
grand personnage que dans la vie ce cas
un mec devait éclater tout le monde à
son époque très avant-garde sur plein de
choses c'était déjà un rebel rebel rebel
bas il faudrait il faut être belle peu
de gens le savent je sais que vous devez
aimer on découvre aujourd'hui c'était un
rebelle
comme bob dylan en plus bon ben je
trouve que le bon j'adore la musique
j'adore m'a proposé de chanter j'ai dit
bon si je chante chante ça inc les
paroles me vont bien
c'est bien j'aurais pu les écrire
vanstar aubin comment ça se passe oui
j'y vois passer de niro arrive nicholson
ou princess passe comment ça se passe
super et ce qui est bien c'est qu'ils
viennent comme s'ils étaient nos
basiques mais oublient qu'ils sont au
queen's où nicole sol de niro ils vivent
leur vie son milieu des autres ils
s'amusent et c'est pour ça qu'ils se
sentent bien mais pourquoi ils vont
aubin vauban parce que d'abord parce
qu'on est là il ya de la bonne musique
et des belles nanas il ya un bien beau
feeling c'est tout simple parce qu'on
les considère pas comme des stars ont
sur les forêts en plus ça leur fait pas
céder ils font un fantasme comment on
est tous les soirs quand lorsqu'on est
normal c'est vrai comment la nuit en ce
moment la nuit ça a beaucoup mieux
à m'échapper avec le cocooning tout le
monde reste à la maison il paraît que ça
c'est un truc qu'ils ont récupérés dans
les journaux pour les hippies des autres
je ne te dis pas il faut qu'il sorte
qu'il faut qu'ils s'éclatent c'est pas
vrai à la fois que je vois autant de
monde toujours dans le chiffre
d'affaires ça va vite à faire ça à mes
défaites il ya toujours du monde le soir
et toujours ça va ou cooning sûrement
tous les autres
avec les boîtes dans les boîtes avec le
sida c'est pas un peu moins peuplées
qu'avant non il faut peut-être plus un
peu plus attention et encore mash des
voix derrière et je les vois je crois
pas mais bon peut-être dans la tête au
moins
entendu parler du blind test
moi j'en ai vu que j'en ai vu
quelques-uns à la télé la télé dans
d'ailleurs quand on émission
était prêt
[Musique]
quant à m speedy gonzales
danyel gérard
avait vraiment sympa c'est un truc que
j'adore ça ça te plait ça apporte une
chaudière c'est la version que j'aime le
moins ah ben ouais mais bon pourquoi
j'ai pas il a vraiment des meilleurs ya
trini lopez déjà j'ai pas mais bon ça va
quand même tu pourrais leur prendre six
mois l'agro gonzalez alors
[Musique]
c'est ma jeunesse
chagnon à en tirer des ponts porte
l'os 3 titres rock avec the strokes
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
plutôt décevante
ces grecs mais avant c'est pas grec
viendront taviaux baba comme toi tu
reconnais pas c'est la patte en attend
ça c'est grave
il ya une sicav quelque part belle est
loin ses habitants la wii
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
ils étaient ranimés bien plus facile que
ça
messieurs la toile et messieurs zoo
keneo baba away ahwach absolument c'est
de la vie ça sera un bateau de ma vie ah
bon toute ma vie ça c'est à vis
de mon pote alors passé august darnell
oui
libéré
les soirs l'ajc mon pote les m'a dit oui
alors bon on était au fond de mes potes
qui chante on est bien
on le sait ce n'est pas par tout le
bijou tout figé
[Musique]
oui là aux abris c'est gentil avec moi
là bah ouais sherritt
genève a besoin de maintenance assez
voilà j'aime toutes les musiques j'ai
cette chance d'apprécier toutes les
musiques lui c'est un des plus grands
musiciens pour moi qui m'en mets le plus
rond plus opulent c'est andreas
andreades colline weill bravo
[Applaudissements]
rapide à jouer comme aliments chauds
sous
la manche ou sachets non pas du mois ça
me fait du tout est filmé dans la tête
ah bon tu plaisantes ou quoi je
comprends mieux ça que je sais pas ce
qui passe à la radio à tout ce qui
pouvait pas jouer un même âge un nom en
permanence pas ça me fait voyager en
permanence ça sans moi je marche qu'à la
flotte senio est ce cela nuage language
ce qui est servi à nouveau les faits
nous ce qui est intéressant de la new
age c'est que aulas il est rayé en plus
il ya le
contrat que j'avais chez moi non plus
non mais la new wave qui est bien c'est
que c'est pas seulement une musique
c'est un état d'esprit suite philosophie
et mon avis dans l'est
les mois et les années à venir on se
moque pas
mais moi les années mais aujourd'hui
comprendra peut-être déjà compris
le souffle pas la gamme à savoir
alors ça petit bout que je connais pas
d' avance ça c'était une genre de
musique on entend toute la nuit avec
boîte de nuit c'est sam jardin des
halles à la salle samedi rien on va à
hue et mes enfants que ça prenne
kaka le sait la part thierry corps qui
quelqu'un le sait lotus et moi je sais
qui c'est qui c'est à l'est oui
numéro un américain des bons alors leur
plan de vol à qui kohl abdullah abdullah
il regagnera j'essaie d'évoquer ses
névroses et
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ouais si zaz ou big eyes et fait du
black sont aux colons sa gicquel et
polyrythmique entre fellah et ray lema
il s'est fait une place de choix après
noir et blanc voici guilty le jury
applaudi le 31 mai les garçons bouchers
à l'elysée montmarte de 2 juin santana à
bercy et 6 mo mac à nouveau mac à
l'elysée montmartre
[Musique]
m
et
non
[Musique]
d
c charest
[Musique]
et
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
m
après l'été
le limougeaud
[Musique]
m
nous
monsieur des voix
monsieur scénario
[Applaudissements]
tandis que l'hiver ce ton vrai nom c'est
hervé forneri en es et tu t'ai appelé
dick rivers à cause d'un film d'elvis
exact qui s'appelle loving you ouais
alors j'ai posé une question quand même
une différence et laquelle le prénom
seddik d'aircal bravo tu vois déjà très
bien
[Applaudissements]
les chats sauvages ça vient du groupe du
père d'une chanteuse
ou là
ah ben ouais tu sais toi c'est quoi les
wildcats marty wild et les wildcats le
père de jim white
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
déjà les chats sauvages ça durait qu'un
seul était quoi ça a duré deux ans où
vient d'observer duré 20 ans oui ça a
duré le premier disque on a fait en
avril 61 je les ai quittés en outre 62
pourquoi on s'entendait plus très très
forte
aujourd'hui que 20 de coûts du rock and
roll faut bien dire par
rmc l'âge d'or de la pac d'âge d'or ça
s'appelle un jour tout course à 383 je
suis très content de le faire parce que
la musique c'est vrai que la tp
hamburger campagnard et rock'n'roll ça
c'est un bouquin qui est sorti à deux
ans qui a bien marché et là je prépare
un roman historique au rock'n roll à ce
long roman 1 qui sortira en même temps
de double album que j'ai fini annonce à
l'entrée qui sort fin août dominique
farrugia rtl j'ai pas depuis des temps
immémoriaux
ah ça c'est quoi 17 ans non écoute j'ai
fait la première prestation j'ai pu
faire tel 162 pour présenter les beatles
apple venait de rouler mais je me suis
arrêté entre temps mais j'ai tout lâché
j'avais envoyé firme à nantes et
directeur adjoint des programmes oui une
femme et services artistiques plus et sa
gran la fête de la musique ouais tu
occupes de la musique et jeux je m'étais
a été journaliste enfin qu'il est
toujours d'ailleurs je s'oublie pas
plus vraiment j'enregistre un peu c'est
pour match aux usa ce qui correspond
on va passer au jeu
[Musique]
enfin les compositeurs alors on dogues
stand by me kansas city giles rock baby
baby et on brode sait pas qui fait même
si
les brestois bravo
à toi maintenant il faut
stopper de même enveloppe
reach out i'll be there la marque alice
les compositeurs
you can't hurry love tu connais pas je
pars de chez soi non berry gordy la
périgordine chez le patron de la maison
[Musique]
non mais je l'aï suprême tous les
fantômes
je connais que l'amante de dire oui
[Applaudissements]
je le vis même registre on put mdr on
continue avec les compositeurs tu es
prêt oui date ce rythme à elvis 54
woippy par macarthur big boys club ouais
[Applaudissements]
bateau shame repris par lennon sur rock
and roll et ma carte et sur back in the
ussr
ouais
les producteurs à iai do you remember
you can always on verra made
in stone karma my sweet lord suspects
bravo
[Applaudissements]
continuez que les producteurs plier aux
normes la halle des arts les yes relax
frankie goes to hollywood video killed
the radio star tu dois connaître sa bile
oui
[Applaudissements]
c'est bien de morrison pas de morrison
légumes bravo
[Applaudissements]
peut écarter bravo
les chanson homonyme il ya une chanson
qui s'appelle doivent my car dans yes à
icade les revenir album de crosby david
crosby 89 et l'autre sayah baby loup qui
doit demain car des beatles sur canal
baba
ould
tu sais le revolver na
un big to fail mais il a dit qu'est ce
qu'il a dit il est au sol
comme tu as dit déjà j'étais sur un
album des beatles ou d'un oui petit
humain petit mot
alors toi tu connais ou oman par bernard
web
mais si tu venais c'est un jour tu as
dit à paul mccartney quelle est la
chanson que tu as écrit deux cas pas eu
de succès
c'est tout cela qu'il
avait écrit pour peter and garden
adacore oui c'est pas possible ou mat il
ya une chanson homonyme par qui me donne
bravo
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
belle forme physique
bon alors on va faire les one hit wonder
or si les mecs qu'on fait qu'un succès
dans leur vie à toi ma carter pas
bravo
quel est le seul tube connu d edwin
hawkins singh soixantaine bible ou non
toi tu sais rapide et ouais
[Applaudissements]
non vraiment
on félicite
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
les fous du malpas réclamons sakho c'est
comme ça
avant papon c'est le concert de qu'elles
font à globo 8 boulevard de strasbourg
en ciboure pense à yann d'amour en 75
minutes de rhodes kalfon allemand rôle
avec ces comètes lucette il fait l'amour
à la gamme avant son album qui sort cet
été et beauté
j'vais les plus d'anti pour tom pas
touché sa colère l'histoire donne raison
à
[Musique]
je suis bien à néant les chichis de
philippe castro et bientôt les parigots
close au vent si gary congas pour les
gars numéro nous à kouba font parler la
salsa les coups bas à l'enfant nous
sommes leurs titres sec et à l'eau
lorsqu'on vend 12 albums à cuba 1er 33
en europe à 14 gatchos à la chapelle
densement marc dos rond des coachs en
bas âge sagan
[Musique]
à
merci
rigolant les mongolo trisomie 21 au
bataclan prolifique les prisonniers
dixième album works
le 8 juin tom jones au palais des
congrès le 8 juin les bee gees à bercy
le 12 juin bat dylan au zénith le 14
juin simply reds et michele [__]
vertes au palace à 20h30 19 juin
fishbone à l'elysée montmartre 19 20
juin simpl minds à bercy 23 juin stray
cats choses et nient
[Musique]
tous accueillera les fadas du fado pour
la sky mazdaspeed passe là où les jets
studio tech pour tous vaches en terre
l'armee d'universitaires en mêlant
protocolaire et biture d'enfer
cette super party la deuxième en europe
pour sa consommation d'alcool après la
fête de la bière de munich c'est unique
2 le samedi 3 juin à 23h45 lunettes
noires et au rock awards c'est la plus
grande concentration de rockstar ever le
samedi 10 juin à 23h15 spécial lunettes
concert sos racisme en direct de
vincennes tous les grands sur scène ce
soir-là les stars sont des potes
[Musique]
apparemment
monde
les deux sur l'addition c'était lunettes
noires pour nuit blanche avec peter
gabriel trudie styler
joe cocker
olivier frébourg
speedy graphito
claude challe
dick rivers dominique phare en salle au
tass band asda ce nas
[Musique]
ah oui
plus haut
[Musique]
à
ouais grave
wiwa
[Musique]
quoi
pour les eaux
d
il
[Musique]
ah
oui
hu
et
[Musique]
oui
bah
[Musique]
m
allez
[Musique]
bah ouais
plus
oui
[Musique]
pour être sauvé raté le in lardy tube
abonnez vous je m'étais un peu ce bleu